the problems will not stop for donald
trump's former supposed fraud lawyer
sydney powell now why do i say suppose
it well you guys if you've been
following the story i've been telling
you about this story for a year now
sydney powell
appeared to be representing donald trump
in various of these frivolous voter
fraud
motions and complaints filed to courts
after the 2020 election but when she got
really cuckoo for cocoa puffs
the white house put out us the trump the
then trump white house put out a
statement saying what she's doing she's
doing on her own and then she was banned
from the oval office but was reportedly
seen there anyway et cetera okay
the latest is that she is now under
federal investigation
um feds are now asking questions about
sydney powell and her pro-trump group
now the details are interesting and
you'll see why in a moment the daily
beast reports ever since sydney powell
spearheaded one of then-president
trump's efforts to nullify the election
she has found herself on the wrong side
of a flurry of potentially ruinous
lawsuits but this is not the only part
of her deepening troubles
for months the federal investigation
running out of washington dc
has been demanding documents and asking
potential witnesses about powell
according to three people familiar with
the matter separately similarly a
separate investigation into powell's
anti-democratic activities took place in
the sunshine state earlier this year and
has already produced results and
punished powell and her far-right group
the federal probe which has not been
previously reported is examining the
finances of defending the republic an
organization founded by powell to fund
her lawsuits to overturn the 2020
election
according to two of the people familiar
with the matter a grand jury was
impaneled and subpoenas and documents
subpoenas and document requests have
gone out to multiple individuals as
recently as september defending the
republic's finances have already
prompted an investigation and a
settlement with florida's charity
regulator they paid a ten thousand
dollar fine
uh in secretly recorded conversations
released by erstwhile powell ally lynn
wood over the last few days former
overstock.com and defending the republic
ceo patrick byrne accused powell of
pocketing funds from the group in order
to pay for her defense against that
billion dollar defamation suit filed by
dominion voting systems they haven't
responded to the comments so this is
very very interesting because
this is about the financing of the
nonprofit
meant to fight the election results not
about her completely outrageous
participation in perpetuating the big
lie with the frivolous bogus legal
challenges against it so it's related to
the insanity she was involved in but
it's actually about the financing of
that insanity not the insanity itself
and of course she may face disbarment
and all sorts of other problems going
forward as well but it's about the
funding of those actions not the actions
themselves she seems quite troubled as a
reminder here was this very strange
interview that she did with um
sarah ferguson um we looked at this a
couple months ago let's get a few simple
facts straight yeah and how many states
were smartmatic machines and software
used in the 2020 election i don't even
know the exact numbers no idea but you
were making some um big statements very
dramatic critical statements about
smartmatic you must have known what
their involvement was in the election oh
you'd have to go look at our complaint
against
with
with respect to the four states that we
filed legal complaints in right to get
the details of that a google search
would have shown you that smartmatic was
operating in one single county in
california
well i'm saying i think their
involvement's probably a lot bigger than
that what research or fact checking did
you do at the time to find out what
smartmatic's actual involvement in the
election was if you work for smartmatic
you've made an allegation against
smartmatic
that they stole a presidential election
i think it's incumbent on both of us to
know what smartmatics involvement was it
seems like a pretty foundational fact i
mean i'm confused right now about why
you're here
because you how did you get into my
house ma'am series of
very strong allegations against
smartmatic and against dominion
containing many errors of fact
do you accept the fact now that the
company that you accused of stealing a
national election only operated in one
county in la in california
one county one state no i'm not prepared
to accept that fact
i think smartmatics involvement was far
more significant than that do i think
they're trying to minimize their
involvement of course i do you said that
smartmatic owns dominion how do you
justify such a basic factual error
i'm gonna stop this interview
so anyway who could have predicted that
this entire thing she got involved in
would have backfired horribly uh so now
under federal investigation and um i
mean i wonder if you ask her do you
regret even getting involved in this
stuff trump abandoned you
your legal trouble federal
investigations humiliating interviews
my instinct is she's not so deluded that
uh she would say no i it was all worth
it my instinct is she would say it
wasn't worth it it wasn't worth it but
we may never know we'll take a quick
break and we will be back right after
this insane new revelations
about covid during the last presidential
campaign involving donald trump and joe
biden
incredible incredible revelations from
mark meadows stay with us it is an incre
an insane story but a completely
predictable one